you know that minor character from the
game that briefly shows up to help Joel
and Ellie how about we make the most
emotionally riveting and heart-wrenching
story about that man's relationship with
Frank that sounds like a good idea to
say the least episode 3 of The Last of
Us I think will be the most polarizing
for fans of the game because it almost
entirely deviates from it the primary
aspect that is retained is the general
plot point of Joel getting a car from
Bill everything else is essentially
different into comparing contrast the
two would be a Fool's errands and if
anything they are so completely
different that would be basically
spoiling the game for its rendition of
events Craig and Neil decide here to opt
for a more light-hearted and happy
exploration of our relationship set
within a depressing post-apocalyptic
world that kind of Direction in of
itself is beautiful because so rarely
are there happy endings in this type of
setting not to mention that we kind of
needed this for how much darker the show
will inevitably get so personally I
think this deviation from The Source
material is outstanding and achieves
such a high quality and storytelling
that it's baffling how well the creators
are pulling it off because generally
when you start to deviate too far from
The Source material issues arise however
for the last of us it's the opposite
every form of deviation is used to
expand the world and further dive into
characters that the game wasn't able to
put a spotlight on Bill in the game was
definitely an interesting character but
here in the show he's brought to life
and we get to witness all of his best
moments this episode as a whole reminds
me of the first 10 minutes of up it's a
story of Two Lovers that is told over
the years as they get older and one of
them succumbs to sickness they both
explore the happiness and beauty of life
and is also a reminder of the sadness
that comes with death and sickness they
obviously have different endings since
Carl doesn't kill himself enough but I
think they both achieve such a
magnificent execution that is imbued
with so much love to the point that
anyone who watches those Works will cry
or come close to it The Last of Us
episode 3 is practically flawless and
has no down moment through the entirety
of its run time if anything I wish the
episode was much longer even though it
was already over an hour long like I
would have gladly watched Ron Swanson
the survivalist build up his defenses in
a zombie apocalypse as a mini-series in
of itself but the Montage we do get from
that sequence is perfect and gives you
just enough in a short amount of time to
fully educate us as do his whole
situation that it was just very
intriguing to see this kind of situation
play out and the practicality and
realism of this type of scenario
thinking about this episode there's only
one nitpick that I could think of and
that was Bill standing out in the middle
of the street shooting Raiders as he was
getting shot at it seemed pretty dumb
that he didn't have a pre-designated
area that he could shoot from that at
least had more cover because his method
here is obviously unsafe especially
since stroll warns him about a Raider
attack the scene prior this again is the
only small flaw in the episode for me
and I think it was just a way for the
writers to injure Bill and to have Frank
save his life and I think everything is
made up for by how brilliant the ending
of the scene was doing a time Jump and
showing a wide shot of a character in a
wheelchair makes the audience
automatically assume that that character
is Bill so it's a Twist just through the
editing and presentation of the story
that it was actually Frank but before
going into their heartfelt ending let's
fully analyze the entire story of Bill
and Frank and the scenes leading up to
this to see why this is HBO's magnum
opus the episode does start out with
Joel and Ellie and for all the people
that said there wasn't enough of them
here I think we get a pretty good amount
from how long the episode was like off
of runtime alone John Ellie are selling
about 27 minutes of the episode their
first few scenes are definitely great
and it exemplifies Joel's refusal to
bond with Ellie given that Ellie's
smuggling mission is the reason for
Tess's death Joel isn't mourning as he
goes on autopilot to carry out the
subjective and most attempts Ellie makes
to talk to Joel are shut down in a way
he blames her and him shutting her out
is a part of his frustration then slowly
through the course of their scenes Ellie
is able to pierce through Joel's thick
exterior and finally gets him to start
talking Ellie does this by asking a
string of questions that Joel can't
really ignore and at a baseline Ellie is
able to make Joel partially open up to
her then the moment where Joel even
makes a quick-handed joke towards Ellie
confirms that this process is working is
there anything bad in here just you ah
getting funnier from here the question
she asks become more and more personal
and require elaboration from those
questions my two favorite were Ellie
asking what it was like to fly in a
plane and her asking about the origin of
the outbreak the education that Joel
provides is really insightful and acts
as both an interesting moment for the
audience because it gives us some
backstory and marks the point where Joel
has moved past his anger towards Ellie
Joel's now the one who's doing most of
the talking and is probably relating
back to the feeling of being a father
where you inform your children through
these 15 minutes we see the
relationships totally change as Joel
starts to open up and even through
Pedro's performance you can see him
admire Ellie from time to time this kind
of nuance and progression for Joel and
Ellie isn't really in the game and the
show offers a more realistic approach
for what Joel would be feeling in these
scenes because in the game they move on
pretty quickly after Tess dies and Joel
and Ellie are always on pretty good
terms like this moment where Joel such
as ground rules for Ellie at the end of
the episode happens right after Tessa's
death in the game there isn't a long
period for Joel to process what happened
to Tess because each main event for the
game is generally surrounded by action
or things to engage the player
gameplay-wise so in contrast this
episode offers a progression for them
that is fulfilled by the end of the
episode when Joel listens to the music
that Ellie puts on at first Joel is
reluctant to show any form of happiness
but he gives in and allows himself to
fully bond with Ellie just within this
under half hour stretch of time it
achieves some great character
development their relationship is more
detailed and realistic and each scene
had an additional aspect that
strengthened it like the suspenseful
moment in the basement the Intriguing
backstories like the people getting
executed and the suicide note that sends
our characters through a roller coaster
of emotions so anyone who is
dissatisfied with the fact that there
wasn't enough progression within this
episode and it didn't entirely feature
Joel and Ellie confuses me when you look
pretty
because not only does Bill and Frank's
story hit so [__] hard but it also is
relevant within the plot given that Joel
and Ellie react to their demise and also
need their truck along with scenes that
fleshed out Joel and Tessa's past with
Bill and Frank even though this episode
is mostly comprised of a self-contained
story The Writers are still able to make
it relevant and they manage to tell one
of the best one-off stories I've seen
for a while and let's finally get into
Bill and Frank's story I don't think I'd
be exaggering when I say that this is
one of the best stories in a
post-apocalyptic setting that has ever
been told the journey we go on with Bill
and Frank is constantly riveting with so
many deeply moving scenes and so many
beautiful little moments that makes the
story feel like a gem in the rough for
this whole section of the episode I
first want to mention the acting Nick
Offerman and Murray Bartlett give
incredible performances and I'll be
surprised if one of them don't receive a
guest starring Emmy nomination for
acting their entire relationship and
evolution is insanely touching and I'll
probably keep thinking about them for
for a while both of their performances
throughout some of their first
encounters are so layered in our
entrenched with so many details to pick
up on you can see Bill struggle to
contain his happiness as he tries to put
on an unmoved Expression he does this to
not allude to the fact that he's liking
the presence of Frank because if he
communicates that then Frank can take
that as a signal to stay along with Bill
getting a little flustered at times that
Frank also picks up on their
performances are subtle enough to
understand what they are going through
precisely in each moment to the point
that it doesn't feel jarring when it's
revealed that bill is gay that in this
moment gives Nick Offerman playing the
piano and singing in such a Whimsical
little moment that even feels like an
escape from our own lives which is
ironic considering that the world they
live in is over like I was genuinely
taken aback for a second during this
wonder-like moment the whole nature of
this scene where a kind man decides to
give a man on the verge of death a
chance a meal a shower and a good time
is extremely wholesome and it reveals
the true nature of Frank he's not a
crazy person and Bill's kindness is paid
off despite bill at first being hesitant
in wanting to play it safe by sending
Frank away but I think he quickly
realizes the opportunity to form a
connection with another human being that
he's probably been missing for a while
and at best it can turn into a romantic
relationship it's just a joyful
experience to witness this because of
how rare the scenario must be in this
Bleak and depressing world even though
this is a post-apocalyptic story I love
how this episode focuses on some of the
small joys of life even through Joel and
Ellie's brief scenes they essentially
carry this notion like through Ellie
finding an old arcade game she loves and
then finding the music in the car the
moment for Bill and Frank that was very
precious was them eating strawberries
for the first time in years this moment
was so happy and beautiful that it
almost feels surreal in a way I think
the cinematography here AIDs that
feeling with how they time the sun to
peer through the trees in the
backgrounds on one side of the frame you
have the sun gushing in with a warm lens
flare while on the other we have Bill
and Frank giving each other a loving
Embrace which this single shot on its
own must have been frustrating because
they probably had a very limited time to
get it the links that the craters are
going to to make this as visually
delightful as possible is great and it
really comes together to create an
unbeatable Aura of Happiness however we
can't just have an episode without any
conflicts all these bejeweling moments
are then contrasted by the Raider attack
and Frank getting an uncurable
life-threatening illness this is where
the episode really feels like up to me
and is a further exploration of that
kind of story concept here in the last
of us our characters are more accepting
of death because they live an extremely
fulfilling life especially given the
fact that the world has ended so seeing
them this happy and living one more
final day of what they perceive as their
perfect life was thoroughly heartwarming
literally every moment within the last
10 minutes of their relationship is the
most I felt in ages I haven't been this
impacted by an episode in every aspect
of production here as always is
unmatched especially the performances
again seeing Nick Offerman breakdown
really destroyed me because this man
kind of exemplifies the manly Trope of
Men Who hide their emotions but here
he's sobbing and realizes that the love
of his life is going to be dead at the
end of the day Nick Offerman can convey
so much emotion and he's a man of few
words like it's truly impressive how
much this man can say through his face
alone I am gushing quite a bit about
Nick offerman's performance here but I
think it's matched by Murray Bartlett
his happy and somewhat calm demeanor
from him accepting death offers a great
contrast to the sadness that Nick is
exuding Murray's performance was so good
in fact that I didn't even notice that
he was the same person who played Armand
in season 1 of The White Lotus he was
just so captivating to learn that he
became the character and I never
pictured him as anyone else this overall
topic of a loved one passing away and
having to accept their wishes is such a
tragic element to explore and I think it
was perfectly done it's sad but it
simultaneously portraying a feels good
moment as these two lovers live out the
last day of their lives together all of
this being sweeped away by violins and
no dialogue further enhances the already
gargantuan feelings that this scene is
extracting from me and it all comes
together to make something amazing then
their final meal was perfectly paced as
they take the time to process what's
happening shots of them staring at each
other lovingly from one last time is
enough to get me swelling up again at
this point the episode has you firmly
locked in with these characters so when
it's revealed that bill also put pills
in the bottle and was going to die I
further raised the scene that was
already in the stratosphere Frank isn't
even Furious Adam and realizes that it
would be hypocritical to be mad at Bill
and equally accepts Bill's wishes that
he wants to die with Frank like I don't
know how the hell Neil and Craig were
able to keep one-upping themselves here
because holy [__] was this a magnificent
ride and for most of the time after the
scene I thought bill would have a
botched suicide or something since he
appears in the game but Neil and Craig
commit to the bit at an aspiring level
to not bringing him back then it's
capped off with a suicide note and even
leads into Joel confronting the loss of
Tess it's staggering how great this
deviation from The Source material is
and if it's going to be this good then
be my guess change as much as you want I
know some people will be mad at them for
changing this much already but keep in
mind the core plot is still the same
it's just the means in which we got here
we're a tad bit different one had more
action while the other decided to pop
off with one of the best recent love
stories even though this focus is on two
minor characters from the game it still
tells a gripping story within this world
that is good enough to take most of the
spotlights on IMDb this episode is
already falling in terms of its rating
it is at an 8.3 currently as of writing
this video which is really surprising to
me I don't know if people are either mad
at the mass deviation or if people were
bored or something because if this
wasn't able to capture you and resonate
with you then I don't know what will I
think this drama is making a great
substitution for all the action in the
game because there's already a lot of
action there and he can't just throw all
that into the show the main complaint I
did see is that Joel and Ellie aren't
the same or aren't being featured enough
but I'd argue The Show Goes in more
depth than the game because the show is
able to focus on the acting more while
the game's story is primarily told
through dialogue when you're navigating
through the world things I pointed out
earlier like Joel dealing with the loss
of Tess is explored way more here than
the game as a comparison that and Joel
and Ellie were still in almost 27
minutes of the last episode and they had
their own mini Arc of sorts so yeah to
me this is essentially HBO's magnum opus
in recent memory and Rivals some of
their best episodes in the past I won't
say it's the flat out best like better
than the red wedding or some of the peak
episodes of Game of Thrones but it's
definitely up towards the top and you
can't beat that final shot of the
episode thank you for watching and let
me know what you guys thought about
episode 3 of The Last of Us
foreign